august is national black business month
and that is one way people can help the
community by supporting those businesses
rocky theis introduces us to one local
businesswoman
continuing to make her way as a local
pioneer in a new industry
hard work dedication motivation drive
that's what comes to mind when keema
ogden the owner of top notch the health
center thinks of black owned businesses
she is one of the only black female
owners in the cannabis industry
and the only one in nevada that has
equity in it i think the common
misconceptions that people have of black
owned businesses
is that we're unorganized
we're cheap we're um
for a lack of a better word ghetto it's
really far from the truth so what she's
saying is
we have to be twice as good as our
counterparts to be successful
you have to be twice as knowledgeable
you have to be
more prepared it definitely
is as a woman in general in a
world of executives that are men
you all already have to do that but as a
minority
it takes it even up a notch hence why
kemah's business
is top notch we're like a big family
here but yet we
compete with some of the big giants in
town and that's a big deal considering
what it took to get here
this industry was built on the on the
backs of minorities you know we've
always been involved
in and um different areas of different
industries and we really don't get
this the justice when it comes to being
able to be involved in the industry when
it finally
materializes and monetizes as a las
vegas native and entrepreneur
there was no better place for keema to
build as a whole there's a lot of
opportunity here you really have to hit
the ground floor though
with change in the industry you want to
be involved in or get
really involved in legislation to make
sure you get a fair
shake at the end of the day as a black
or minority business owner
it's not about you it's about your
community
and that's how you stay strong we are
very fortunate because
the community we do a lot of community
advocacy work we do a lot of community
give back
i've done that prior to this business
i've always been involved in that
and i think that's why the community as
a whole gives back as well to us
they support us we support them